une première mondiale est une nouvelle
étape dans la lutte contre la pandémie
le vaccin développé par les laboratoires
américains et allemands pfizer et
biotech est le premier à être
officiellement approuvé le pdg du
laboratoire américain jubile et a salué
ce matin un moment historique tandis que
les britanniques de leur côté crie
victoire
le gouvernement a accepté aujourd'hui la
recommandation de l'agencé indépendante
de réglementation des médicaments et des
produits de santé d'approuver
l'utilisation du vaccin contre le coc
vite 19 de files heures biotech
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson a salué sur les réseaux sociaux
une nouvelle fantastique seulement dix
mois après le début de son élaboration
c'est le vaccin le plus rapide jamais
conçu pour passer du concept à la
réalité des étapes qui s'étale
normalement sur une décennie
le royaume uni a déjà commandé 40
millions de doses suffisamment pour
vacciner 20 millions de personnes
la campagne est donc imminente dans le
pays c'est une fantastique nouvelle que
lé agences de réglementation des
médicaments et des produits de santé
organismes de réglementation clairement
indépendant est autorisée cliniquement
le vaccin pour un déploiement ultérieur
le système national de santé est prête à
y parvenir
donc dès le début de la semaine
prochaine nous entamerons le plan de
vaccination de la population contre le
colis de 19 dans ce pays le vaccin d'une
efficacité de 95 % selon pfizer et
biotech sera d'abord inoculé aux
personnes prioritaires
ainsi les résidents des maisons de
retraite le personnel soignant et les
plus vulnérables devraient être les
premiers à en bénéficier dès la semaine
prochaine